there are a lot of people out there who
want to talk trash about your family and
say that you're a child abuse victim
whatever and I'm here to say that's not
true i am nick gillespie with reason TV
and today we're talking with zach Wahls
the author of my two moms lessons of
love strength and what makes a family
Zach thanks for talking to us thanks
Riley you broke through into kind of
YouTube consciousness in 2011 tell us
about what were you testifying for and
what were you saying so I was testifying
for the Iowa House Judiciary Committee
during a public forum on hjr 6 which was
a constitutional amendment that would
have reversed the 2009 Supreme Court
decision that legalized same-sex
marriage in Iowa and the most immediate
after effect of that hearing on my life
was kind of this rocketing well you you
became a kind of poster boy for you know
the upside of same-sex marriage that you
know these families are not particularly
different from heterosexual marriages
you know what should people take away
from your story there were really two
key demographics I was trying to reach
with this book the first was other kids
who have same-sex parents they're just
kind of be a voice and say look I think
there are a lot of people out there who
want to talk trash about your family and
say that you're a child abuse victim
whatever and I'm here to say that's not
true and second also wanted to make sure
that I had a good message for people who
are on the fence and who thought you
know gay people they can do what they
want to do that's their right but in
terms how does that affect kids what do
you think is the biggest misconception
that outsiders have about children in a
same-sex marriage they're probably too
really large misconception the first is
that there's something inherently
immoral about homosexuality and
therefore the children will be somehow
immoral and as part of that maybe I
could corollary this you know this
thought that sexual sexual orientation
is a choice or a learned behavior in the
devil's own horrible and so that any
lesbians first off are always going to
have girls and they're going to turn
them into lesbian Thomas sexuals always
going to have boy kids and turn them gay
yeah yeah
in there i mean it's ridiculous reverse
anybody who actually knows you know a
same-sex couple it looked there are some
gay parents who have gay kids it's a
very small minority well in the book you
mentioned also that you know up at least
through this point in history
heterosexual parents are the leading
cause of gay kid that's right that's
true I mean nobody looks at Ellen
DeGeneres and says yeah those straight
parents are at it again yeah we're
talking not long after President Obama
has come out and said that he's in favor
personally anyway of same-sex marriage
what do you think of that is that a
positive development or is it a cynical
political ploy yeah you know I think
that you can have both be true I think
there's certainly a level of political
calculus that went into it but as
somebody who growing up has never been
represented by a president who believed
that the sanctity of my mother's unions
was valid to now have a sitting
president who supports them I don't
really care why he said it I care more
that he did in fact say it the gay
interests are usually allied with the
Democratic Party or with a liberal
economic intervention yet a lot of gay
people actually resent the state or
top-down control and regulation that
often comes with that how do your
politics play out particularly as the
son of a Velez being fo sho I
self-identify as an anti-authoritarian
liberal awesome kind of joke colloquy if
I'm a liberal tarian so to speak I think
there are certainly some instances where
you have corrosive state behavior and I
think gay people especially are very
attuned to this and even as the son of
the same sex couple who's not gay I was
very attuned to that they're also a
number of times though where state
intervention is completely necessary
schools are a great example you have a
lot of I've got a very close friend the
man who grew up in Grinnell Iowa about
10,000 people Grinnell College is in in
Grinnell Iowa and she went through some
really you know hard stuff growing up in
public school system because the way
that her teachers just didn't care and
more willing to step in on her behalf
when she was being mocked for having
same-sex parents there's a little bit
less true for me growing up in Iowa City
which is a more progressive community
thing Grinnell but at the end of the day
they're certainly going to be some
instances not necessarily many but
certainly some were stated intervention
in my opinion is warranted they were
going to be many more obviously with
like DOMA is a classic example there's a
defense of marriage and a sense of an
egregious violation of the ten
the moment to be sure but then also
there are some lots of other issues at
play there you run through a bunch of
the kind of characteristics of scouts
one that is not mentioned as a chapter
heading i believe is be prepared you
know if you're talking to America as a
country what should America be prepared
to understand going forward about issues
revolving around same-sex marriage and
about the families that come up in that
in that situation I think the the
biggest preparation so to speak is going
to have to be willing to make the effort
that it takes to understand somebody
coming from a different perspective
coming from that alternative family
alternative in terms of like a numbers
game not necessarily at normalcy game
that's a very kind of careful Walt line
to walk but in terms of people having to
sit down and really move past some of
these stereotypes and misconceptions
that we've seen be disproved not just
through empirical science but also
anecdotally with stories like mine and
you know some of the other two million
kids out there with an LGBT parent or
parents and so it's it's hard you know
and but that's ultimately the
responsibility that comes with the power
to shape public policy in this country
is you know the responsibility to sit
down and really work through these
issues on a person-to-person level and I
think it's going to take some
preparation but I think in a lot of ways
we're already moving towards that place
already right so I mean a positive
pluralism and if not necessarily an
approval of things in acceptance
tolerance but do your parents talk about
what it was like 20 30 or 40 years ago
versus now and I think everybody would
say there's you know there's been a lot
of progress but is it enough or when
when do we when will we stop writing
books about yeah coming you know where
the hook is oh I'm the kid of a zoo of a
game I hope yes really you know this is
certainly not something that I hope to
do for an extended amount of my life
because I hope it's something that
doesn't need to be done you know 10 15
years from now but they answered the
first part of the question you know
there was kind of this interesting kind
of you curve of what it was like having
lesbian parents and so far as how it was
seen by my peers when I was in like
kindergarten through third grade it was
like you have two moms hey I want to
moms like it was a very positive thing
and then fourth grade fifth grade it's
like you have you've gay parents that's
weird and then a lot of time I got the
high schools like dude you
lesbian parents are they hot yeah it's
like oh come on guys but I think more
broadly we are going to see that you
like flattened out you know my mom's
often kind of say like they never
thought they'd see same-sex marriage
legalized in their lifetimes let alone
in Iowa so there have definitely been
some pretty incredible developments even
in the last decade you've gone from
thirty-eight percent depending on the
pole two fifty three percent you've seen
really some seismic moves in that
direction that doesn't surprise me at
all we've been talking with zach Wahls
the author of the new book my two moms
lessons of love strength and what makes
a family for reason TV i'm nick
gillespie thanks Zach thanks
you